ich habe hier auf meinem und auf anderen
youtube kanälen ja schon häufig über
künstliche intelligenz und die gefahren
dahinter gesprochen dass eine generelle
ki intelligenter als jeder mensch werden
könnte und uns dann so behandelt wie wir
ameisen behandeln relativ gleichgültig
genau wie wir 99 prozent unserer
entscheidungen treffen ohne dabei über
ameisen nachzudenken könnte eine super
intelligente entscheidungen treffen die
wir nicht mal ansatzweise verstehen
aber obwohl die möglichkeit dafür in der
zukunft besteht sind roboter schon heute
gefährlich beinahe alle drei tage gibt
es in deutschland einen unfall mit einem
industrieroboter diese roboter sind
nicht intelligent führen immer dieselben
bewegungen aus und dennoch kommt es
durch schlecht designte
sicherheitsvorkehrungen ständig zu
unfällen
wir müssen also erforschen wie man
maschinen sicherer machen kann und wo
geht das besser als im future work learn
hier wird an den arbeitswelten der
zukunft geforscht und ich schaue mir die
spannendsten aspekte davon jetzt einmal
an
[Musik]
für das wissenschaftsjahr 2018
arbeitswelt der zukunft bin ich dieses
mal nach stuttgart gefahren
hier ist das feature work lab und auch
konstantin der daran arbeitet roboter
sicherer zu machen
was wir hier sehen ist ein demonstrator
zu mensch roboter kollaboration spricht
zur zusammenarbeit zwischen mensch und
maschine
das interessante an der sache ist hinter
mir ist ein großer roboter sprich einer
der normalerweise in einer fabrik
arbeitete normalerweise auch getrennt
von den menschen arbeiten auch ein fan
von den menschen arbeiten muss das tolle
an der ganzen sache jetzt einfach dass
wir den quasi dazu gezwungen haben an
zahlen zu sein und den menschen während
der arbeit nicht zu gefährden und sogar
zu unterstützen das funktioniert über
drei kameras die den bereich um den
roboter arm herum ständig beobachten
bewegt sich etwas unerlaubterweise in
den sicherheitsbereich hinein wird der
roboter sofort gestoppt
ja also wenn ich jetzt das system quasi
stören würde oder bei der arbeit stören
würde und einfach jetzt manchmal rein
bewege werde ich als objekt erkannt auch
drüben auf dem bildschirm sieht man es
dann werde ich auch als punkt wolke
dargestellt die schutzbereiche werden
durchsichtig ja auf dem bild dargestellt
so dass man nicht auch als werker die
visuelle rückmeldung hat okay ich
befinde mich jetzt im sicherheitsbereich
finde ich jetzt wieder raus gehen würde
dann läuft die arbeit automatisch weiter
das funktioniert extrem schnell und auch
bei ziemlich kleinen objekten selbst
wenn man in den sicherheitsbereich
hineinstolpern sollte ist man vor den
bewegungen des roboterarms geschützt ein
ganz ähnliches system hat tabea mit
ihrem team für sägen entwickelt wir
haben ein sicherheitssystem entwickelt
damit die säge unfälle verhindert weil
momentan gibt es hat so eine vertikal
beim serie lediglich schon not aus knopf
und den drückt man natürlich erst
nachdem der unfall passierte
und wir haben jetzt eine stereokamera
interniert die eben den unfall schon
verhindert weil die blatt die säge
bleibt stehen sobald eben eine hand in
den gefahrenbereich kommt und wie jede
gute erfinderinnen ist tabea von ihrer
schaffung so überzeugt dass sie sie auch
selber demonstriert
ich kann ganz normal segen das heißt ich
kann mit dem werkstück in den
gefahrenbereich eindringen aber wenn es
jetzt zum beispiel meine hand hier vorne
dran mache und an dieser grand prix
serie sofort
der unterschied zum system von
constantin ist dass die säge objekte
identifizieren muss während der roboter
bei jedem objekt das in seinen
sicherheitsbereich kommt stoppt muss die
serie zwischen etwas das zersägt werden
darf und zb einer hand unterscheiden
können einen nachteil hat das system
dadurch allerdings und wenn jetzt ein
holzstück hätte das genauso aus wie eine
hand
vielleicht auch nicht bearbeiten
arbeitsunfälle werden durch diese
technologie also hoffentlich bald
seltener eine sache darf in der zukunft
natürlich nicht fehlen
das ist ein exoskelett das hilft mir
dabei schwere gegenstände zu
transportieren und der ansatz dabei ist
eigentlich dass sich entlastet wird das
heißt in gewisser anteil von dem gewicht
übernimmt das exoskelett das
funktioniert so wir haben hier an der
seite aktiv im motor
die gegen eine unterstützung von
gewissen newtonmetern
wenn man das umrechnet dann kommen die
ungefähr bei einem 20 kilo 25 kilo
koffer auf 50 prozent entlastung
die idee ist also nicht dass man mit dem
exoskelett unbedingt mehr heben soll
sondern dass man bei gewichten die man
auch so heben könnte unterstützt wird
viele schäden zieht man sich nämlich
still und heimlich zu über jahre hinweg
durch falsche körperhaltung und
überlastung
dieses modell ist natürlich nur ein
prototyp und mit 17 kilogramm gewicht
auch noch nicht wirklich für den
arbeitsalltag geeignet aber das könnte
sich schon ziemlich bald ändern
also was ich mir vorstellen könnte dass
es eben einzug hält über diese felder wo
es unbedingt notwendig ist und darüber
wird dann auch die entwicklung besser
sein ich kann mir vorstellen im moment
ziehen vielleicht 1900 mhz im automobil
bei den extras kennen also vielleicht
wichtigen drüber und so wie es beim
rother eben auch ist da fängt da an bei
denen sie geld haben und da wo es nötig
ist mein ende hat es jeder
ich denke nicht dass es jeder hat ein
ende beim exoskelett aber das ist in
vielen der bereichere eingehen wird
na da bin ich mal gespannt was meint ihr
tragen wir in der zukunft alle
exoskelett um unseren rücken zu schonen
ich denke an so ein anblick könnte man
sich eigentlich relativ schnell gewöhnen
aber diskutiert doch gerne mit mir unten
in den kommentaren
ich möchte mich auf jeden fall beim
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video bedanken es war ziemlich
cool in stuttgart beim future world cup
zu drehen
leider konnte ich euch nur einen ganz
kleinen teil von all den dingen zeigen
an denen dort geforscht wird aber
vielleicht komme ich ja noch mal wieder
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]